I had the chance to meet with some of
the kids in the program today.
Where are you screaming at?
There you go.
I love those kids.
And so when I thought I would do,
because they gave me a little bit of
time to say whatever I want,
um,
is offer you a little bit of
some observations for your future.
I have five little rules that you can
follow as you find your spark and bring
your spark to life.
The first is to go after the things that
you want.
Let me tell you a story.
So a friend of mine and I,
we went for a run in central park,
the roadrunners organization,
uh,
on the weekends.
They host races and it's very common at
the end of the race they'll have a
sponsor who will give away something
apples or bagels or something.
And on this particular day when we got
to the end of the run,
there were some free bagels and they had
picnic tables set up.
And on one side was a group of
volunteers on the table were boxes of
bagels.
And on the other side was a long line of
runners waiting to get their free Bagel.
So I said to my friend,
let's,
let's get a Bagel.
And he looked at me and said,
uh,
that line's too long.
And I said,
free Bagel.
And he said,
I don't want to wait in line.
And I was like,
free Bagel.
And he says,
Nah,
it's too long.
And that's when I realized that there's
two ways to see the world.
Some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want.
I could only see the bagels.
He could only see the line.
And so I walked up to the line.
I leaned in between two people,
put my hand in the box and pulled out
two bagels and no one got mad at me
because the rule is you can go after
whatever you want.
You just cannot deny anyone else to go
after whatever they want.
Now I had to sacrifice choice.
I didn't get to choose which Bagel I
got.
I got whatever I pulled out,
but I didn't have to wait in line.
So the point is is you don't have to
wait in line.
You don't have to do it the way
everybody else has done it.
You can do it your way,
you can break the rules.
You just can't get in the way of
somebody else getting what they want.
That's rule number one.
Rule number two,
I liked this one
in the 18th century,
there was something that spread across
Europe and eventually made its way to
America.
Fever,
also known as the black death of child
bed.
Basically what was happening is women
were giving birth and they would die
within 48 hours after giving birth.
This black death of childbirth was the
ravage of Europe and it got worse and
worse and worse over the course of over
a century.
In some hospitals,
it was as high as 70 percent of women
who gave birth,
who would die as a result of giving
birth,
but this was the renaissance.
This was the time of empirical data and
science,
and we had thrown away things like
tradition and mysticism.
These were men of science,
these were doctors and these doctors
that men of science,
I wanted to study and try and find the
reason for this black death of child bed
and so they got to work studying and
they would study the corpses of the of
the women who had died and in the
morning they would conduct autopsies and
then in the afternoon they would go and
deliver babies and finish their rounds
and it wasn't until somewhere in the mid
18 hundreds that Dr Oliver Wendell
Holmes,
father of Supreme Court justice Oliver
Wendell Holmes,
realized that all of these doctors who
are conducting autopsies in the morning
weren't washing their hands before they
delivered babies in the afternoon and he
pointed it out and said,
guys,
you're the problem.
And they ignored him and called him
crazy for 30 years until finally
somebody realized that if they simply
washed their hands,
it would go away.
And that's exactly what happened when
they started sterilizing their
instruments in washing their hands,
the black death of child bed
disappeared.
My point is,
the lesson here is sometimes your the
problem.
We've seen this happen all too recently
with our new men of science and
empirical studiers and these men of
finance who are smarter than the rest of
us until the thing collapse and they
blamed everything else except
themselves,
and my point is,
is take accountability for your actions.
You can take all the credit in the world
for the things that you do right as long
as you also take responsibility for the
things you do wrong,
it must be a balanced equation.
You don't get it one way and not the
other.
You get to take credit when you also
take accountability.
That's lesson two.
Lesson three,
take care of each other.
The United States Navy seals are perhaps
the most elite warriors in the world,
and one of the seals was asked who makes
it through the selection process,
who is able to become a seal?
And his answer was,
I can't tell you the kind of person that
becomes a seal.
makes it through buds,
but I can tell you the kind of people
who don't become seals.
He says,
the guys that show up with huge bulging
muscles covered in tattoos,
who want to prove to the world how tough
they are,
none of them make it through.
He said,
the preening leaders who like to
delegate all their responsibility and
never do anything themselves,
none of them make it through.
He said,
the Star College athletes who've never
really been tested to the core of their
being,
none of them make it through.
He says,
some of the guys that make it through
are skinny and scrawny.
He said,
some of the guys that make it through
you will see them shivering out of fear.
He says,
however,
all the guys that make it through,
when they find themselves physically
spent emotionally spent,
when they have nothing left to give
physically or emotionally,
somehow some way,
they are able to find the energy to dig
down deep inside themselves to find the
energy,
to help the guy next to them.
They become seals.
He said,
you want to be an elite warrior.
It's not about how tough you are.
It's not about how smart you are.
It's not about how fast you are.
If you want to be an elite warrior,
you better to get really,
really good at helping the person to the
left of you and helping the person to
the right of you because that's how
people advance in the world.
The world is too dangerous in the world
is too difficult for you to think that
you can do these things alone.
If you find your spark,
I commend you now who you going to ask
for help and what are you going to
accept?
Help when it's offered.
Learn that skill.
Learn by practicing,
helping each other.
It will be the single most valuable
thing you ever learned in your entire
life to accept help when it's offered
and to ask for it.
When you know that you can't do it.
The amazing thing is when you learn to
ask for help,
you'll discover that there are people
all around you who've always wanted to
help you.
They just didn't think you needed it
because you kept pretending that you had
everything under control and the minute
you say,
I don't know what I'm doing,
I'm stuck.
I'm scared.
I don't think I can do this.
You will find that lots of people who
love you will rush in and take care of
you,
but that will only happen if you learn
to take care of them
first.
Less than four.
Nelson Mandela is a particularly special
case study in the leadership world
because he is universally regarded as a
great leader.
You can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to,
we have different opinions about other
personalities,
but Nelson Mandela across the world is
universally regarded as a great leader.
He was actually the son of a tribal
chief and he was asked one day,
how did you learn to be a great leader?
And he responded that he would go with
his father to tribal meetings and he
remembers to things when his father
would meet with other elders.
One,
they would always sit in a circle and to
his father was always the last to speak.
You will be told your whole life that
you need to learn to listen.
I would say that you need to learn to be
the last to speak.
I see it in boardrooms everyday of the
week.
Even people who consider themselves good
leaders who may actually be decent
leaders will walk into a room and say,
here's the problem,
here's what I think,
but I'm interested in your opinion.
Let's go around the room.
It's too late.
The skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things.
One,
it gives everybody else the feeling that
they have been heard.
It gives,
gives everyone else the ability to feel
that they have contributed,
and two,
you get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion.
The skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself.
If you agree with somebody,
don't nod yes.
If you disagree with somebody,
don't not know.
Simply sit there,
take it all in and the only thing you're
allowed to do is ask questions so that
you can understand what they mean and
why they have the opinion that they
have.
You must understand from where they are
speaking,
why they have the opinion they have,
not just what they are saying and at the
end you will get your turn.
It sounds easy.
It's not practice being the last to
speak.
That's what Nelson Mandela did,
number three,
number five,
monty python,
one,
two,
five,
three
for all the other nerds in the audience.
There's one.
Number five,
my favorite.
One of all,
true story.
There was a former under secretary of
defense who was invited to give a speech
at a large conference about a thousand
people and he was standing on the stage
with his cup of coffee in a Styrofoam
Cup giving his prepared remarks but his
powerpoint behind him and he took a sip
of his coffee and he smiled and he
looked down at the coffee and then he
went off script and he said,
you know,
last year I spoke at this exact same
conference last year.
I was still the under secretary and when
I spoke here last year,
they flew me here business class and
when I arrived at the airport there was
somebody waiting for me to take me to my
hotel and they took me to my hotel and
they had already checked me in and they
just took me up to my room and the next
morning I came downstairs and there was
someone waiting in the lobby to greet me
and they drove me to this here,
same venue.
They took me through the back entrance
and took me into the green room and
handed me a coffee,
a cup of coffee in a beautiful ceramic
cup.
He says,
I'm no longer the under secretary.
I flew here,
coach.
I took a taxi to my hotel and I checked
myself in.
When I came down the lobby this morning,
I took another taxi to this venue.
I came in the front door and found my
way back stage and when I asked someone,
do you have any coffee?
He pointed to the coffee machine in the
corner and I poured myself a cup of
coffee into this here,
Styrofoam Cup.
He says,
the lesson is,
the Ceramic Cup was never meant for me.
It was meant for the position I held.
I deserve a Styrofoam Cup.
Remember this,
as you gain fame,
as you gain fortune,
as you gain position and seniority,
people will treat you better.
They will hold doors open for you and
they will get you a cup of tea and
coffee without you even asking.
They will call you sir and Ma'am and
they will give you stuff.
None of that stuff has meant for you.
That stuff has meant for the position
you hold.
It has meant for the level that you have
achieved of leader or success or
whatever you want to call it,
but you will always deserve a Styrofoam
Cup.
Remember that?
Remember that lesson of humility and
gratitude.
You can accept all the free stuff.
You can accept all the perks.
Absolutely you can enjoy them,
but just be grateful for them and know
that they're not for you.
I remember getting off the Esella.
I took the Esella from New York to
Washington DC and I got off the train
like everybody else and I was walking
down the platform like everyone else and
I walked past general nordies Schwartz
who used to be the chief of staff of the
United States air force,
the head of the air force,
and here I did you see a guy in a suit
schlepping his own suitcase down the
platform just like me and just a couple
months ago he was flying on private jets
and eight an entourage and other people
carried his luggage,
but he no longer held the position and
so now he got to drag his own suitcase
and never did it.
Sort of remind me more that none of us
deserve the perks that we get.
We all deserve a Styrofoam Cup.
It was a pleasure meeting you guys this
afternoon.
I was blown away by your honesty and
your curiosity and your poise,
and I am confident that the future is
bright despite the fact that America
looks like an absolute mess right now.
I am confident that the future is bright
for one reason and one reason only
because you will grow up and you will be
our future.
Thank you very,
very much guys.
You're wonderful.